here at ET we actually have a
speed-dating game okay okay maybe you
guys will find me somebody
[Music]
we're gonna do a fast seven for the
speed-dating round camp
if you could have dinner with anyone
dead or alive who would it be okay I
have a little celebrity crush you know
who I think is so sexy the the actor
from girls trip will tell my girls trip
was it hoping Kofi you know very sexy so
yes what's your ideal first date with
Kofi on the spot my ideal first date
hypothetically speaking um just good
conversation good food and wine all
right no you can't go wrong with wine
and conference and food wine
conversation of food and yeah the next
part is a little scary-looking Netflix
turn it's an expletive chill you go to
Kofi in the neck legs I don't know in my
app and I'm just saying just kill what
is the soundtrack to your life
ooh the soundtrack to my life girl
disrupt it currently I just rusted
everything you need to know about seven
is in that album
[Music]
what's the worst first date question
that you've ever heard probably
something a lot of so you met a whole
lot of famous people huh it's like check
please check please
Oh something we'd be surprised to know
about you oh so many works surprised
this is so bad I'm obsessed with dr.
pimple popper on Instagram what I like
okay what I swear to God is so gross my
mom is like you were just disgusting
I could watch dr. pimple popper on
Instagram like all day I just sit there
fascinating like oh how she gonna get
this one out it's very good but I also
heard that kind of heart it's also
obsessed with dr. popper so I'm gonna
pull so bad okay we can watch dr. pimple
popper together let's make that happen
the most embarrassing childhood memory I
was a little older but it's still
something that happened when I was
younger and it was very embarrassing so
in one of my girl groups I was on tour
Beyonce and I'm singing them performing
I'm performing I go and no and I throw
my mic out into the audience Oh on a
Beyonce tour now this is a rich girl
this is a really it was so embarrassing
and I just kept dancing and singing it
in and the girls was like hey this thing
together
it was so embarrassed Oh
biggest pet peeve people who stand too
close to me in lines it drives my neck
if you're that close to what you keep
stepping on my heel then clearly you're
too close remember the thing you do in
elementary school you hold your own give
me sleepy feet okay you're - I can't
stand it last thing from our fast 7 our
speed 8 most reckless thing you've ever
done I will say this and it's not really
that reckless but I guess it kind of is
I always misplace my license a lot when
I'm going to the airport and that's
really reckless because I have shells
and I have to get to and if I don't make
it my fans are gonna kill me and cuss me
out
[Music]
you